Welcome back. In all these cases up to now, we've assumed that we know the
population parameters, mu and sigma. But much of the time, we don't. We often
only have samples, which we must then use to draw all our conclusions. In the
next two lessons, we'll use samples to find out how different a sample mean is
from a population, and how different two samples are from each other. Out of
all the measures of center, we usually use the mean. Now, the two samples we're
comparing in this case, can either be dependent or independent. We'll go over
these differences later. In lesson ten, we're going to look at these. And then
in lesson 11, we'll look at independent samples. It's going to be fun. When we
work with samples, we have to estimate the population standard deviation using
the samples standard deviation with Bessel's correction. Remember this from
Lesson 4? Normally, to find out how typical or atypical a sample mean is, in
what you did before, as we would find its location on the distribution of
sample means, the sampling distribution. And we can determine the shape and
parameters of this sampling distribution if we know the population parameters.
Remember that for any sample mean, we can find where it falls on this
distribution by standardizing. In other words, finding the z-score of the
sample mean. We find the difference between the sample mean and mu, and then
divide by the standard error. But now, the standard error depends on the
sample, we can no longer us sigma if we have a sample. Therefore, we end up
with a new distribution that is more prone to error. This is called the t
distribution. Since it's more prone to error, then it's more spread out and
thicker in the tails than a normal distribution. Remember from lesson seven
when you learned that larger sample sizes result in skinnier sampling
distributions? That same principal applies here. So what do you think happens
as n, the sample size, increases? The standard error increases? The
t-distribution approaches a normal distribution? The t-distribution gets
skinnier tails? And finally, s, the sample center deviation, approaches sigma.